avec vous l ain phrase bonjour hélène
bonjour pauline énormément de réactions
donc ce matin dans la presse et votre
revue de presse sera consacré à ce sujet
donc à cette possibilité probabilité de
voir la cour suprême américaine
écrasée l'arrêt qui avait accordé aux
femmes américaines le droit à
l'avortement c'était en 1973 dont la
décision d'annuler la règle veut que ce
soit et ce n'est pas un choix
conservateur c'est un choix radical
indignation et mise au point ce matin du
new york times être conservateur c'est
penser que les changements brusques
faisait profond des lois sont totalement
destructeur du respect de ses lois et
des institutions établies pour les faire
respecter mais annuler la décision de
1973 reviendrait à allumer un feu
culturelle supplémentaire dans un pays
déjà enflammé par les questions raciales
les programmes scolaires la justice
pénale les lois électorales ou encore
les diverses théories du complot la cour
suprême risque de ne jamais se remettre
d'une annulation d'euros versus wade le
washington post évoque lui aussi un
projet radical une preuve supplémentaire
de la dérive politique de la cour
suprême annule les rovers ce soit et
dropt restreindrait la liberté et serait
une répudiation répugnante de la
tradition américaine selon laquelle la
liberté c'est un cercle toujours plus
large d'individus en trahissant cet
héritage et en se rangeant du côté d'une
minorité d'américains hostile à l'aide
décision de 73 les juges ne se comporte
pas en jeu restent impartiaux mais en
idéologue imprudent dangereusement
déconnecté et hostile à ce qui est
pourtant au coeur de l'éthique
américaine washington post qui souligne
les conséquences politiques d'une
éventuelle remise en cause du fameux
arrêt 73 d'après le journal une telle
décision risque de bouleverser on l'a
évoqué les élections de mi-mandat qui se
tiendront lieu en novembre prochain et
de polariser encore un peu plus la
campagne avec une mobilisation massive à
la fois chez les démocrates et les
républicains
autour de cette question de l'avortement
des droits individuels et autour de tout
ce qui oppose leur philosophie si
contrastées je cite dans le si de joe
biden qui a appelé ses compatriotes à
défendre le droit à l'avortement dans
les urnes le dessinateur pat burns on le
voit accuse la cour suprême de ne pas
vouloir s'arrêter là ce n'est pas une
décision finale il ya d'autres droits
que nous aimerions annulé fait-il dire
un juge cette inquiétude est d'ailleurs
partagée par adam qui glisse qui montre
la barque de la liberté et des droits
des femmes prendre l'eau sur le point de
couler bob une grotte lui s'indigne de
voir les juges menacé le droit des
femmes à disposer librement de leur
corps avec ce dessin qui montre un
utérus devenu la propriété de la cour
suprême des etats unis la presse
conservatrice américaine ellen accusé
les démocrates de chercher à
instrumentaliser la question de
l'avortement le wall street journal
considère que les fuites sur les
discussions en cours au sein de la cour
suprême constitue je cite un abus de
confiance sans précédent
un acte de malveillance face auquel les
juges ne devrait pas se laisser
intimider comme toujours la question est
de savoir à qui profite le crime le
quotidien pointe du doigt la gauche et
les médias américains dont la réaction
apocalyptique aurait pour but en réalité
de discréditer la cour suprême qui est
largement acquise désormais au camp
conservateur renversé euro ne serait pas
là sein de l'avortement en amérique mais
on verrait simplement cette question aux
états qui seront libres de restreindre
d'interdire ou de faciliter le droit à
l'avortement nuance le journal le
washington times pauline tente lui aussi
de minimiser la portée d'une éventuelle
remise en cause de l'arrêt 313 en
assurant que le nombre d'avortements aux
etats-unis et de toute façon à un niveau
historiquement bas le journal cite ce
commentaire de l'animateur de radio
conservateur eric ericsson vous avez
plus de chance de connaître un couple
homosexuel marié que de connaître
quelqu'un qui a avorté
beaucoup de réactions également du côté
hélène de la presse européenne de
revenir sur la rosace ce soit l'aide
serait une catastrophe pour les droits
humains de gardienne quotidien
britannique évoque le sombre
aboutissement d'une croisade menée par
des fanatiques contre la volonté de la
majorité une menace pour la santé le
bonheur est là des femmes savent orizet
selon lui par l'héritage juridique de
donald trump en allemagne le frankfurter
allgemeine zeitung dénonce un combat
culturel mené sur le dos des femmes en
prédisant une remise en cause de la
décision de 73 conduirait les états
gouvernés par les républicains à se
lancer dans une course à celui qui sera
le plus rapide et le plus impitoyable
pour interdire le droit à l'avortement
en france libération cite simone veil
hélène qui avait porté la loi encadrant
bien sûr la dépénalisation de
l'avortement ici en france adopté en
1974 c'était un an après l'arrêt
américain de 73 n'oubliez pas qu'il
suffira n'oubliez jamais qu'il suffirait
d'une crise politique économique aux
religieuses pour que les droits des
femmes soient remises en question ces
droits ne sont jamais acquis vous devrez
rester vigilante votre vie durant
libération appelle à défendre le droit à
l'avortement aux états unis et partout
ailleurs y compris en europe où l'on
empêche actuellement les ukrainiennes
victimes de viols d'avoir accès à l'ol
j'ai al ahly vg pardonnez moi en pologne
les autoproclamés provigent ne
laisseront jamais les femmes tranquille
mais nous ne les laisserons jamais
revenir en arrière tranquillement pour
mais le journal merci beaucoup et
l'aisne on vous retrouve à 9h20 on
parlera aussi de la stratégie anti
qu'ovide de la chine dans la presse